What kind of music helps you relax? Maybe something classical? How about this? Different kinds of music can certainly alter how we feel or even how fast our heartbeats. But what effect does music have on our brains or even our health? In this episode, a neuropsychologist discusses how research is changing the way we understand the power of music. I'm Audrey Hamilton, and this is speaking of psychology. Psychologist Daniel Levedon is a professor of psychology.
什么样的音乐能帮你放松？也许是古典音乐？那这个呢？不同类型的音乐确实可以改变我们的感受，甚至改变我们的心跳速度。但音乐对我们的大脑甚至健康有什么影响呢？在本期节目中，一位神经心理学家将探讨研究如何改变我们对音乐力量的理解。我是奥黛丽·汉密尔顿，这是《心理学谈话》。心理学家丹尼尔·列维京是一位心理学教授。
behavioral neuroscience and music at McGill University in Montreal. A former rock musician and studio producer, he now studies the neuroscience of music and how music impacts our mental and physical health. He's also the author of the bestselling book, This Is Your Brain on Music. Thank you for joining us, Dr. Levedon. Thank you for having me. I don't think it's surprising to most people that music can impact us emotionally. You know, music moves people. But when it comes to our health, such as pain management or stress. How does music impact our brains? Can music even replace medicine in some situations? Well, it depends on what you mean by medicine. Lots of things that we do affect our physiology. Exercise does, and so we could say that exercise replaces medicine when it has the desired outcome
他在麦吉尔大学研究行为神经科学和音乐。作为一名前摇滚音乐人和录音室制作人，他现在研究音乐神经科学，以及音乐如何影响我们的身心健康。他也是畅销书《你的大脑与音乐》的作者。感谢您加入我们，列维京博士。谢谢你的邀请。我认为大多数人并不惊讶音乐能在情感上影响我们。你知道，音乐能打动人。但当谈到我们的健康，比如疼痛管理或压力时，音乐是如何影响我们大脑的？在某些情况下，音乐甚至能取代药物吗？嗯，这取决于你所说的药物是什么意思。我们做的很多事情都会影响我们的生理机能。运动也是如此，所以当运动达到预期的结果时，我们也可以说运动取代了药物。
in terms of our physiology, our mental and our physical physiology. And we've seen evidence now that music can alter brain chemistry and even the production of cytokines, immunoglobulin A, and other components of the healthy immune system. When we talk about music therapy and music interventions, you know, what's the difference? In other words, what does the term intervention mean? In the literature, there's a tendency to talk rather loosely about music therapy without respecting the definition of music therapy by the American Music Therapy Association.
就我们的生理、心理和身体生理而言。我们现在已经看到证据表明，音乐可以改变大脑化学物质，甚至改变细胞因子、免疫球蛋白A以及健康免疫系统其他成分的产生。当我们谈论音乐疗法和音乐干预时，你知道，它们有什么区别？换句话说，干预这个词是什么意思？在文献中，人们倾向于随意谈论音乐疗法，而不尊重美国音乐疗法协会对音乐疗法的定义。
So I've tended to use the word music intervention as a term more broadly to talk about musical interactions that aren't necessarily music therapy. Just to clarify, music therapy is the evidence-based use of music in clinical situations to help people reach desired health outcomes. and it's normally practiced by a licensed music therapist, a music therapy practitioner, and there are special training programs for that.
所以我倾向于使用音乐干预这个词，作为一个更广泛的术语，来谈论那些不一定是音乐疗法的音乐互动。澄清一下，音乐疗法是在临床情况下基于证据使用音乐，以帮助人们达到预期的健康结果。它通常由持证音乐治疗师、音乐治疗从业者进行，并且有专门的培训项目。
So if we use the word music therapy generically, the way we use Kleenex to refer to any tissue, we're not being precise. So a number of us in the field have opted for the word to reserve music therapy for things that fit that definition that involve a licensed music therapist and use musical intervention just to mean anything else. So if somebody's listening to music or they're engaged in guided imagery or they're playing an instrument in a therapeutic context or an experimental context, but it doesn't conform to the definition of the American Music Therapy Association, then it's music intervention. Can you give me an example of what a music intervention, I mean, I know you said it's a very broad term, but in your research, what would you consider a music intervention?
所以如果我们像使用“Kleenex”指代任何纸巾一样泛指音乐疗法，那就不够精确了。因此，我们领域内的一些人选择将“音乐疗法”一词保留给符合该定义、涉及持证音乐治疗师的事物，而使用“音乐干预”来指代其他任何事物。所以，如果有人在听音乐，或者他们在进行引导性意象，或者在治疗环境或实验环境中演奏乐器，但它不符合美国音乐疗法协会的定义，那么它就是音乐干预。你能给我举一个音乐干预的例子吗？我知道你说这是一个非常广泛的术语，但在你的研究中，你会认为什么是音乐干预？
Well, a music intervention would be in a hospital where you're doing an experiment and you might randomly assign some people in a pre-operative staging area to relaxing music and other people to a Valium and other people to a placebo. That's not being conducted, if it's not conducted by a licensed music therapist and it's not following their protocols, then it's an intervention and not music therapy. But a lot of what the work that, you know, I know that you have analyzed and looked at, at and conducted yourself is focusing on just more evidence-based research on how music affects us.
嗯，音乐干预可能是在医院里，你正在做一个实验，你可能会随机分配手术前准备区的一些人听放松音乐，另一些人服用安定，还有一些人服用安慰剂。如果这不是由持证音乐治疗师进行的，并且没有遵循他们的协议，那么它就是干预，而不是音乐疗法。但是，我知道你分析过、研究过并亲自进行过的很多工作，都集中在关于音乐如何影响我们的更多循证研究上。
Yeah, well, I'm glad you mentioned the evidence-based part because there's been a lot of pseudoscience and just a lot of anecdotes about music, but relatively little actual experiments, true experiments in science. But the direction that it's going is that in the last five years, people are increasingly conducting controlled experiments with proper controls and with proper methods. And we're finding that early evidence, you know, there's not a whole lot of work on which to base this, but early evidence is that music can alter pain thresholds,
是的，我很高兴你提到了循证部分，因为关于音乐有很多伪科学和轶事，但科学中真正的实验相对较少。但发展的方向是，在过去五年里，人们越来越多地进行带有适当对照和适当方法的受控实验。我们发现早期证据——你知道，没有太多的工作可以作为基础——但早期证据表明音乐可以改变疼痛阈值，
that it can increase immune system function. There's stronger evidence that it can affect mood and heart rate and respiration rate. So fast-stimulating music stimulates the production of adrenaline. and other hormones that get your heart racing faster and your pulse increases and blood pressure increases and then soothing relaxing music has the opposite effect. The interesting thing here is that what I'm calling stimulating or relaxing music is relative. It's subjective to the listener. It doesn't work so well if the experimenter or the therapist says, I'm playing you some stimulating
它可以增强免疫系统功能。有更强的证据表明它可以影响情绪、心率和呼吸频率。快速刺激的音乐会刺激肾上腺素和其他激素的产生，使你的心跳加快，脉搏增加，血压升高，而舒缓放松的音乐则有相反的效果。这里有趣的是，我所说的刺激性或放松性音乐是相对的。它对听众来说是主观的。如果实验者或治疗师说“我给你放一些刺激性的音乐”，效果并不好。
music. The person has to find it stimulating themselves. And how do you determine that? How do you determine what someone finds more relaxing than another person? Well, we usually just ask them. We ask them to bring in a piece of music that they find stimulating or relaxing. So that part of it's subjective. And people are pretty good at that. What do you find the most intriguing about where this research is going? I think that it's, in some cases, it's going to confirm intuitions that many people have about how music can function in their lives. So we're already in a place in a time where people are using music as medicine.
听者必须自己觉得它有刺激性。你如何确定这一点？你如何确定一个人觉得什么比另一个人更放松？嗯，我们通常只是问他们。我们让他们带上一段他们觉得有刺激性或放松的音乐。所以这部分是主观的。人们在这方面做得很好。你觉得这项研究的发展方向中最引人入胜的是什么？我认为在某些情况下，它将证实许多人关于音乐如何在生活中发挥作用的直觉。所以我们已经处于一个人们正在使用音乐作为药物的时代。
They're using music much as they use drugs. The average person hears five hours of music a day, and many people instinctively reach for a certain kind of music to suit certain occasions. So if you're having a party, you play one kind of music. If you're relaxing after a long day at the office, you play another kind of music. The kind of music you play when you're trying to wake up in the morning is different than the kind you play when you're trying to go to sleep at night. Now, not everybody does this, but a large number of people report in surveys that they're in effect programming
他们使用音乐就像使用药物一样。普通人每天听五个小时的音乐，许多人本能地选择某种音乐来适应特定的场合。所以如果你在开派对，你会播放一种音乐。如果你在办公室忙碌一天后放松，你会播放另一种音乐。你早上起床时播放的音乐类型与你晚上睡觉时播放的音乐类型不同。现在，并不是每个人都这样做，但大量的人在调查中报告说，他们实际上是在编程
music to suit a desired mood outcome. And so in that sense, they're using music for mood regulation. Right. Is it really the music that's affecting us, or is it the act of listening to music? You know, sometimes people listen to it for distraction purposes. There has been some work where people try to find something that's equally distracting. So you can, you can, you can, hold distraction constant and intentionally engaging, something equally intentionally engaging. And it seems as though I wouldn't say music has special properties, but it has the ability to distract or engage in ways that other stimuli don't. But it's a very complex multidimensional stimulus. There's a lot going on there.
音乐以适应预期的情绪结果。所以从这个意义上说，他们正在使用音乐进行情绪调节。没错。真的是音乐在影响我们，还是听音乐的行为在影响我们？你知道，有时人们听音乐是为了分散注意力。有一些研究，人们试图找到某种同样分散注意力的东西。所以你可以保持分散注意力的程度不变，并有意地参与同样需要有意参与的事情。似乎我不会说音乐有特殊的属性，但它确实有以其他刺激物所没有的方式分散注意力或吸引注意力的能力。但它是一个非常复杂的多维刺激。里面有很多东西。
You've got rhythm and you've got timbre and you've got pitch and loudness and they're all changing. They're correlated changes, but they're changing. And so it's a very highly structured medium. You often hear about how listening to classical music can make us smarter, you know, even babies. Is that true? What have you learned about how music affects our cognitive abilities? I think you're, yeah, you're referring to the paper that came out many years ago by Rousher and her colleagues that music, listening to Mozart for 20 minutes makes you show improvement on IQ tests was the headline. And there had been a lot of studies by a number of people, including Bill Thompson and Glenn Schellenberg and others, that have pretty much debunked that.
你有节奏、音色、音高和响度，它们都在变化。它们是相关的变化，但它们在变化。所以它是一个结构非常严密的媒介。你经常听说听古典音乐能让我们更聪明，你知道，甚至是婴儿。这是真的吗？你对音乐如何影响我们的认知能力有什么了解？我想你指的是多年前Rausher和她的同事发表的那篇论文，标题是“听20分钟莫扎特音乐能让你在智商测试中表现出进步”。很多人，包括Bill Thompson、Glenn Schellenberg和其他人，都做过很多研究，基本上已经推翻了这一点。
But there are tantalizing clues in the literature that music is doing some things. I think the people in the field disagree about the size of the effect and the importance of it. But the emerging picture is that not so much listening to music, but learning to play an instrument and being a player can confer some advantages in other areas. It seems to provide attentional training, and on the social side, kids who play in musical groups in elementary school and grammar school tend to be more well socialized. And you can sort of spin a story about why that might be, although that doesn't mean it's science. But a kind of post facto story would be well. If you're playing an instrument in a little ensemble, you've got to coordinate your actions with other kids.
但文献中确实有一些诱人的线索表明音乐正在做一些事情。我认为该领域的人对这种影响的大小及其重要性存在分歧。但新兴的图景是，与其说是听音乐，不如说是学习演奏乐器并成为一名演奏者，这可以在其他领域带来一些优势。它似乎提供了注意力训练，而在社交方面，在小学和文法学校参加音乐团体演奏的孩子往往社交能力更好。你可以编造一个关于为什么会这样的故事，尽管这并不意味着它是科学。但一种事后的解释是，如果你在一个小合奏团里演奏乐器，你必须协调你和其他孩子的行动。
You've got to listen to what they're doing in order to make your part fit. And so you've got to step outside yourself and become a little bit more empathetic. In that respect, it's kind of like team sports and they confer the same advantages, as opposed to passive listening, which doesn't appear to confer those advantages. That's interesting. Well, thank you so much, Dr. Levin, and I really appreciate you taking the time, and this has been very, very interesting. Thank you.
你必须倾听他们在做什么，以便让你的部分与之契合。所以你必须跳出自我，变得更有同理心。在这方面，它有点像团队运动，它们带来了同样的优势，而不是被动聆听，后者似乎并没有带来这些优势。这很有趣。好吧，非常感谢你，列维京博士，我真的很感谢你抽出时间，这非常非常有趣。谢谢。
Thank you. For more information on Dr. Levitin's work and to hear more podcasts, visit our website at speakingofpsychology.org. With the American Psychological Associations, Speaking of Psychology, I'm Audrey Hamilton. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
谢谢。有关列维京博士工作的更多信息并收听更多播客，请访问我们的网站speakingofpsychology.org。我是美国心理学会《心理学谈话》的奥黛丽·汉密尔顿。本集还没有评论。点击转录中的任何句子即可发表评论。